foreign
comes from Ryan in Virginia Ryan writes
I have some friends that are trying to
achieve Financial Freedom through
retailing MLM products online and
networking with other MLM multi-level
marketing retailers they are a very
sweet very sincere but seemingly very
innocent couple I think you mean
innocent as in naive naive the wife does
take on occasional outside work
currently but I wonder how much of her
income is absorbed back into trying to
make their MLM business work I haven't
yet asked them what their net annual
revenue income is from the MLM they've
been at it for two years or if they keep
track of actual hours put into their
business what's an hourly wage Etc but
before I do I want to ask if mlms are
still the Shady barely legal pyramid
schemish companies they used to be or
what your views on mlms are I haven't
found much good said about them online
what do you think about them and what
might you suggest in way of having a
conversation with my friends about it
um
Federal Trade Commission
says that 99 of the people that join an
MLM lose money
that's a staggering statistic it's hard
to actually believe I'm not sure I do
believe it
um the AARP did a different study that
came with different numbers came with
different results so I haven't looked
into the methodologies on the studies to
tell you but they say that
um 27 of people that join an MLM
actually make a profit
um and that 70 you know whatever the
balance is 73 percent lose money uh not
quite as uh harsh as the FTC number but
um I think if you've just got good
walking around sense and you've got a
few decades under your belt you can we
can all agree that the vast majority of
people that started in the MLM do not
make money they lose money whether it's
well in excessive half so there's a high
probability that this couple
statistically speaking has actually lost
money but then has made no money for the
hours they've invested so
um and that's just a observation that's
not actually a moral statement it's not
an Ethics statement I'm not saying
whatever whatever what did he say here
barely legal pyramid that's I'm not
saying any of that the bottom line is
just the people that get in generally
don't make it
um and so it generally makes the top
five percent of the people in the thing
uh they make all their money off of
recruiting and uh people buying the kits
that uh or whatever it is they buy when
they become a recruit and you know or
sign up for the licensing or whatever it
is they have to do and the uplines make
money on that or they go
um
they go sell what you know the
methodology generally what happens is
life insurance companies do the same
thing uh they hire someone young and
inexperienced uh with absolutely very
little uh belief that that person is
going to be with them for 10 years but
they use them to get to their closest
Circle of Friends their Uncle John and
their uh you know their grandpa Dave and
they use them to get an appointment
because they couldn't get in to see John
or Dave but when you know the nephew
calls up is just out of college and he's
24 we'll let them come over with because
he's in training with his boss and so
they'll come over and Pitch your life
insurance it's called working your
natural market and but when they use up
the uh the person's uh call list of what
they call their natural market the
people that they actually have
credibility with then they've they've
run their course and the person can't
make money and so eighty percent of the
people that join the life insurance
world to sell life Insurance are out of
the business in one year
and that's not a multi-level thing it's
life insurance so but it's the same
concept here they work your natural
market so they recruit someone and then
takes you take them to Mom and Daddy you
take them to your brother you take them
to your high school friend uh who will
let you in the door but they wouldn't
let anybody else in the door otherwise
and you recruit them or you sell them
make up or whatever it is you're going
to sell them whatever the multi-level is
doing right
um and so I do personally know
a handful of people that have made Seven
figures in that world I know another guy
who got so who used to speak for him all
the time got so disillusioned with the
fact they were making more money selling
books to the motivational books and
tapes to Their audience than they were
running the actual business the business
was like a seminar business behind the
scenes and he he was part of it because
he was one of the speakers and he got so
disillusioned with that he quit he
wouldn't speak for him anymore and he's
a professional speaker and author to
this day and you'd know his name if I
named it but he won't he won't work with
him anymore but he worked with him for
years he was very well known in their
ranks
um and so all of that to say
um
if you tell me you're in an MLM because
it's a great part-time job I'll tell you
statistically you're a fool
if you tell me you're in an MLM because
you want to grow a large sales
organization and you have a skill set
that helps you to become a sales manager
to 100 or to a thousand people uh or 100
people that have a hundred people that
have a hundred people uh I'm gonna tell
you might get rich you might be one of
the handful that makes a ton of money
but in the meantime the people that join
are inordinately bothersome to the rest
of us
you hate to see them coming don't you it
can be pretty tough it can be pretty
tough oh you're going to be nice about
this aren't you well I it can be real
tough I always appreciate the young kids
when they're hustling and and trying to
sell me Cutco or something
Cutco runs the exact same model too not
multi-level but they run the work the
Natural Market yeah I mean I always
appreciated some this yeah they get
their dads so I got a lot of their dad
gum knives because Sharon won't keep
them out of my house but it I think one
of the most bothering bothering great
knives yeah they're incredible nice
bother some things about this
question is um that if Ryan was sitting
with me the guy who wrote in and asked
this question
I would say hey have they ever even
asked you your opinion yeah because this
guy sounds like he's spending a ton of
time
um he's already made up his mind
wondering what their finances are like
and whether they're making the right
decisions whether they're doing with it
like man you don't get a vote unless
they ask you in and so if they ask you
in
then you can give your opinion but and
it doesn't sound like they're asking you
in it sounds like you're just waiting
for a chance to say hey what you're
doing is wrong an evil
and Ben what are you doing yeah
yeah that's true yeah you're those
convinced against their will are of the
same opinion still and talking someone
that's in an MLM out of being in one is
about like trying to get somebody that
loves crypto to not buy crypto or to
argue somebody out of their religious
stance this is not gonna work
or who they vote for yeah
I mean Trump has caused all kinds of
problems climate change everything else
well people that hate Trump hate him for
for things he never even did it's
amazing everyone hates every politician
for things they never even did that's
true I saw a great one the other day it
was uh it was like a library and Obama
was sitting at a table and he had a
chocolate chip cookie and a glass of
milk and he picked it up and the
chocolate chip cookie was way too big
and he tried to dip it in the milk and
he got all mad and he goes thanks Obama
yeah everybody plays your money for
everything all the time
I'm with you I'm with you yeah so yeah I
agree with John in that sense Ryan mind
your own business it's not your problem
yeah but um let's say yes but what do we
think about mlms uh in general I'm not
mad at them if you want to go do one be
prepared to be a recruiter and a sales
trainer
and and be prepared to manage a high
turnover organization
and if you want to do that and that's
your call you have a chance of making
this into a career making money none of
them are good part-time jobs
statistically
[Music]
um and so you can do a lot better things
on your side Hustle